ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 27
a bis 27c Beratung der Unterrichtungen
durch die Bundesregierung über den
Bericht des Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland 2022
sowie über den Jahresbericht der
Bundesregierung zum Stand der deutschen
Einheit 2021 und wir beraten auch den
Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem
Titel 32 Jahre deutsche Einheit
Schutzschirm gegen Inflation und
armutspannen Lohn- und renteneinheit
herstellen für die Aussprache ist eine
Dauer von 39
ein neuer Blick wurde Ende September von
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung für
Ostdeutschland Carsten Schneider
vorgestellt dieses Format soll sich
künftig in jeweils zweijährigen Rhythmus
mit dem traditionellen Bericht zum Stand
der deutschen Einheit abwechselnd und
Carsten Schneider Staatsminister im
Kanzleramt Beauftragter der
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland fängt
an vielen aufsetzen dieses
Jahresberichts der heutigen Debatte hier
im Freitag im Bundestag wir hatten am
dritten am 3 oktober in Erfurt die
Feierlichkeiten danke auch sehr der
Bundestagspräsidentin für ihre Rede dort
und ich habe eine Veränderung
vorgenommen
es findet für 2022 nicht der übliche
Jahresbericht zum Stand der deutschen
Einheit statt sondern wollte ein Bericht
zum Auftakt der Legislatur machen der
den Blick ein wenig weiter tun auch
erweitert und auch die Zivilgesellschaft
einbindet im nächsten Jahr wird es den
üblichen Jahresbericht auch wieder geben
den wir für 22 hier diskutieren dazu
habe ich 16 Gastautoren eingeladen
Autoren Autoren aus unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen Hintergründen aus
unterschiedlichen Regionen die kritisch
über den derzeitigen Stand aber
insbesondere auch über die große Chance
und Potenziale Ostdeutschlands schreiben
die Beiträge die zeigen die
Umsetzungsschwierigkeiten aber auch die
Herausforderung auch die Freiheit die in
Ostdeutschland sich Baden gebrochen hat
und dieses Land geprägt hat und auch
Deutschland insgesamt stärker gemacht
hat
es ist in der vergangenen Jahren eine
neue eigene Energie und Dynamik
entstanden und vor allen Dingen auch an
neues Selbstbewusstsein ich lege den
Bericht den Wert Schwerpunkt ist bei
unserer auf die gestaltungsschancen und
auf die vielen aktiven Bürgerinnen und
Bürger vor Ort die sich für die
Gesellschaft und für die Demokratie
einsetzen
der Titel lautet ein neuer Blick denn zu
lange standen die Defizite
Ostdeutschlands im Mittelpunkt der
öffentlichen Debatte der
Vergleichsmaßstab war stets der Westen
zu dem der Osten aufschließen sollte
ein neuer Blick das bedeutet auch zur
Kenntnis zu nehmen das ostdeutsche
Besonderheiten nicht einfach irgendwann
verschwinden werden sie fordern und
bereichern unser Land das heutige
Deutschland ist kein Westdeutschland
plus sondern ein neues vielfältiges Land
inmitten Europas
und war es übrigens auch es hat man bei
vielen soli-debatten in vergangen 30
Jahren gehabt der natürlich auch im
Osten gezahlt wurde Westdeutschland wäre
auch allein ein ärmeres Land heute als
Ostdeutschland
und das nicht nur ökonomisch sondern
kulturell und ich glaube auch menschlich
die die gute Entwicklung Ostdeutschlands
belegen auch die vielen
Unternehmensansiedlungen der jüngsten
Zeit ich war es am Montag in Magdeburg
hat den Vertretern des Chipherstellers
Intel gesprochen der dort investiert
begleitet und unterstützt durch die
Bundesregierung und auch die
Landesregierung tausende Arbeitsplätze
im Bereich der Halbleiterindustrie
werden dort entstehen
ein neuer Blick das heißt jedoch nicht
die Probleme zu verschweigen im
Gegenteil die Herausforderung des Ostens
und auch Unzufriedenheiten werden offen
benannt und sie stehen auf der Agenda
dieser Bundesregierung oben
zum Beispiel die niedrigen Einkommen
zum Glück hat die Bundestag beschlossen
dass zum ersten Oktober vielen Dank
dafür auch noch für die Mehrheit die das
mitgetragen hat den Mindestlohn auf 12
Euro zu erhöhen das bedeutet für über
eine Million Menschen höhere Einkommen
allein der Landkreis Sonneberg im
schönen Thüringen 44 Prozent der
Beschäftigte
sozialversicherungspflichtig
Beschäftigten dort verdienen unterhalb
von 12 Euro das heißt 44 Prozent derer
Menschen haben von dieser
mindestlohnerhöhung profitiert dass das
Mindeste was wir geben können der Rest
müssen ja Tarif die Tarifparteien
bewerkstelligen dafür haben sie auch die
volle Unterstützung für mehr
Tarifbindung und auch gewerkschaftliche
Organisierung und auch die der
Unternehmen in ihren Verbänden durch die
Bundesregierung auf die Bundeskanzler
oder nehmen wir zogen auf die Defizite
die Tatsache dass die Ostdeutschen zwar
17 Prozent der Bevölkerung ausmachen
aber nur 3,5% der Führungsposition
begleiten da läuft etwas schief in
Deutschland und zwar in allen Bereichen
deshalb arbeiten wir an Bundesregierung
und meinem Staat bei einem Konzept für
den Bund die Vielfalt unserer
Gesellschaft nicht nur auf ostdeutsche
bezogen sondern insgesamt auch für Leute
mit Migrationshintergrund diese zu
erhöhen und diese Repräsentanz Lücke die
es gibt die vieler für die Akzeptanz von
demokratischen Entscheidungen mit sich
bringt zu verändern und auch mehr
ostdeutsche insbesondere auch Frauen in
Führungspositionen zu halten
liebe Kolleginnen
vielen Dank für die Unterstützung in den
vergangenen neun Monaten vielen Dank
insbesondere auch für die Unterstützung
für das zukunftszentrum und die
Entscheidung die wir insbesondere auch
für die Unterstützung der Chemie und der
raffineriestandorte treffen konnten
herzlichen Dank
folgt für die cdu/csu-fraktion Friedrich
Merz
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren es ist eine
interessante Abweichung von der
bisherigen Übung nicht nur den Bericht
der Bundesregierung zum Stand der
deutschen Einheit einmal im Jahr zu
diskutieren sondern heute auch einen
Bericht des Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland und
dies mit einem anderen Blick wie sie
sagen Herr Schneider zu versehen
entscheidend wird sein dass wir auch in
Zukunft regelmäßig Gelegenheit haben uns
mit den besonderen Herausforderungen des
Ostens unseres Landes zu beschäftigen es
darf nicht zur pflichtgemäßen Routine
werden sondern muss ein wichtiger
Gegenstand unserer Beratungen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag bleiben
jenseits der Berechtigten
wirtschaftlichen Anliegen der
Bevölkerung in diesem Teil unseres
Landes müssen wir vor allem über die
deutlich abnehmende Zustimmung zu
Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft sprechen
dies ist für ganz Deutschland
besorgniserregend und für den Osten ganz
besonders ich möchte aus meiner Sicht
drei Argumente oder drei Vorschläge
unterbreiten wie wir dem begegnen können
zum einen wir dürfen nicht nur reden wir
müssen zuhören und das haben sie mit
ihrem Bericht und auch den Autoren die
sie dort haben zu Wort kommen lassen
getan Herr Staatsminister das ist eine
gute Idee aber wir müssen auch
wir werden auch für eine längere Zeit zu
akzeptieren haben dass die Menschen in
Ostdeutschland andere Lebenserfahrungen
mitbringen andere Biografien mitbringen
und dass sie sich seit über 30 Jahren in
einem geradezu permanenten
transformations- und Anpassungsprozess
befinden das haben wir im Westen so Nied
sondern Streit in der Sache gehört dazu
aber
nach dem Streit nach dem Streit muss es
Entscheidungen geben und diese
Entscheidungen müssen plausibel und
nachvollziehbar sein und erlauben Sie
mir dass ich das an dieser Stelle sage
mit dem Streit in der Bundesregierung
über einen äußerst kritischen Sommer
2022 über die Lösung der Energieprobleme
der einkommensprobleme der
wirtschaftlichen Probleme unseres Landes
über mit diesem langanhaltenden und bis
heute nicht endgültig gelösten Streit
haben sie der Demokratie und der
marktwirtschaftlichen Ordnung gerade im
Osten unseres Landes kein Dienst
erwiesen meine Damen und Herren was
hätten sie anders und besser machen
müssen
Ludwig Erhard hat in seinem wichtigsten
und ja einzigsten Buch das er
geschrieben hat Wohlstand für alle es
war eine Publikation die er geschrieben
hat und die wichtigste in seinem Buch
Wohlstand für alle ein Versprechen
abgegeben dass die soziale
Marktwirtschaft die ich finde im Westen
unseres Landes in geradezu
beeindruckender Weise für fast alle
Menschen erreicht hat aber wir haben es
nicht im Osten erreicht und deswegen
möchte ich Ihnen den Vorschlag machen
dass wir in den nächsten Wochen einmal
darüber sprechen wie wir das große
Defizit an Vermögen an Wohlstand durch
Vermögen im Osten ausgleichen können wir
werden mit der bisherigen Methodik
zu lange warten müssen wenn wir es denn
überhaupt jemals erreichen wir haben
erprobte Modelle im alten Westen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gab für die
Vermögensbildung und die
Vermögensbildung in Arbeitnehmer am Hand
meine Damen und Herren ist das letzte
große nicht eingelöste Versprechen der
christlichen Soziallehre der
evangelischen sozial-etik und damit auch
der sozialen Marktwirtschaft wir werden
da etwas nachholen müssen gerade für den
Osten
und erlauben Sie mir dass ich
abschließend sage
die Qualität eines Landes die
Streitkultur und das Miteinander in
einer offenen freiheitlichen
Gesellschaft entscheiden sich jenseits
von Angebot und Nachfrage die Qualität
von Kultur und Sport sagen etwas
fundamentales aus über unser Land über
unser Gesellschaft unsere Gesellschaft
und gerade über Ostdeutschland und
deswegen will ich mich hier ausdrücklich
dazu bekennen dass wir den Sport und die
Kultur im Osten besonders fördern im
Sport ein großartiges Ergebnis das
endlich in der Fußball-Bundesliga zwei
Vereine aus dem Osten ganz oben in der
Spitze mitspielen das ist ein sehr
erfreuliches Ergebnis aber meine Damen
und Herren auch in der Kultur und in der
Kunst es ist nicht nur das Gewandhaus in
Leipzig es ist nicht nur das
Kindertheater in Dresden es ist auch so
ein Theater am Rand in einem kleinen Ort
Zollbrücke ganz in der Nähe der
polnischen Grenze die hier zum Gelingen
der deutschen Einheit durch Kultur
beitragen und deswegen lassen Sie mich
am Schluss zitieren was unser früherer
Bundespräsident der einzige der bisher
aus dem Osten kam gesagt hat als er auch
einmal seinen Blick auf den Osten und
auf unser ganzes Land gerichtet hat er
hat gesagt mir ist am wichtigsten dass
die Menschen in diesem Land wieder
lernen dass sie in einem guten Land
leben dass sie lieben können weil es
ihnen die wunderbaren Möglichkeiten gibt
in einem erfüllten Leben Freiheit zu
etwas und für etwas zu leben meine Damen
und Herren das ist ein wahres Wort
unseres früheren Bundespräsidenten zur
deutschen Arbeit
Friedrich im März war das der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
hier mit einer nachdenklichen Rede einer
der wenigen westdeutschen die ich hier
zu diesem Bericht zu diesen Berichten
sprechen in dieser Debatte nächster
Redner ist nun Michael Kellner
Parlamentarischer Staatssekretär beim
Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute
wird der Osten auf der Landkarte
international Investoren als Hotspots
wahrgenommen das zeigen Tesla oder Intel
auch übrigens weil wir dort so viel
erneuerbare Energien haben jetzt dürfen
wir auf diesem Weg nicht nachlassen und
auch nicht in Ostdeutschland auf der
Kohle hocken bleiben es braucht auch in
Ostdeutschland wie in NRW ein
Kohleausstieg 2030 die Zukunft des
Ostens liegt in einer
Wasserstoffwirtschaft und nicht in der
Kohle
mit Blick auf Schwedt und Rostock bauen
wir eine grüne Chemie und Grüne
raffinerin aus diese Zukunft
unterstützen wir mit Simon 250 Millionen
Euro in einem GLW Sonderprogramm über
die kommenden 15 Jahre kurzfristig
blicken wir auf die Energiepreise hier
ist das Gebot der Stunde Entlastung von
Haushalten und Firmen gerade den
Mittelstand die Bundesregierung hilft
hier mit inzwischen drei
entlastungspaketen und auch in diesem
Jahr mit einer Gas- und strompreisbremse
so sichern wir Existenzen und Jobs in
vielen von den hohen Energiepreisen
betroffenen Branchen auch bei der
Lohngerechtigkeit profitieren gerade in
Ostdeutschland die unteren
Einkommensgruppen von der deutlichen
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns auf 12 Euro
sehr geehrter Herr Merz ich habe ihre
Aussagen zur Vermögensbildung sehr genau
gehört finde ich sehr gut dass sie das
angesprochen haben ich will ausdrücklich
sagen daran sollten wir gemeinsam
zwischen der demokratischen Opposition
und der Regierung dran arbeiten
wenn ich im Osten unterwegs bin treffe
ich Menschen die sich für ihren Ort den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und
unsere Demokratie engagieren es gibt
ihnen anderen Osten viel mehr als manche
denken hier stellen sich
menschenrechtsextreme und
Verschwörungstheoretikern aller koreur
mutig entgegen sie treten für ihre
Gemeinde ihre Region ein Arbeiten an zu
unsfähigen Jobs in einer gesunden Umwelt
an der Seite dieser Menschen müssen
demokratische Kräfte stehen
Demokratien
Demokratien scheitern wenn Demokraten
die Türen nach Rechtsaußen aufmachen
Demokratien scheitern wenn schwierige
Entscheidungen nicht erklärt werden
sondern nach dem Munde geredet wird das
sind alle demokratischen Parteien
gefordert meine zum Beispiel die
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine zu
begründen doch das gilt auch das gilt
auch für die Union und lieber Herr Merz
das würde ich gerne aufnehmen ihren
Gedanken sie machen um die Demokratie
gesprochen wenn ihre
Mittelstandsvereinigung in Brandenburg
gegen Waffenlieferungen wird keine
vorurteilung von Russland zustande
bringt und wenn bei Veranstaltungen der
mittelstandsunion Rufe laut werden die
Regierung vor Gericht zu stellen dann
ist es Aufgabe einer Partei sich solchem
Irrlichtern entgegenzustellen weil ich
ich traue ich glaube ihren Aussagen nur
dann müssen wir auch gemeinsam in den
Wein entgegenstellen oder wenn die
Brandenburger Finanz- und Europa
Ministerin wie die Vertretung des
gremmels an Landtags spricht deswegen
danke an die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der SPD-Fraktion die da klar
widersprochen haben
und wenn linke Montagsdemonstration
Kapern wollen dann ist es eine
Geschichtsvergessenheit vor über 30
Jahren sind mutige Menschen auf die
Straße gegangen die nicht wussten ob sie
abends nach Hause zu ihren Kindern
kommen oder ob sie im Knast landen
deswegen ist der Missbrauch der Monat
aus Demonstration so schäbig haben
diesen Missbrauch abgrenzen so wie es so
treffen an der gezählt man die Kirche in
Berlin steht denkt ein Banner 22 ist
nicht 1989 wir leben in keiner Diktatur
herzlichen Dank
Michael Kellner hat hier noch einmal
auch auf das Demokratie Verständnis
hingewiesen das war ein doch
überraschender Befund in diesem Bericht
Ostdeutschland 2022 wie wenig mit der
Demokratie zufrieden sind
live Erik Holm jetzt für die
afd-fraktion Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ich will am Anfang
feststellen Kollege Merz hat es schon
angesprochen wo der Osten ist ist vorne
das gilt auch in der Fußball-Bundesliga
der erste fC Union Berlin ein kleiner
bodenständiger Verein ganz ganz oben aus
Köpenick mit wenig Mitteln unterwegs
aber mit dem eisernen Willen die
Bundesliga aufzurollen und das ist doch
schon ein gutes Ergebnis gestern 1:0
gegen Malmö der freut sich denn nicht
wunderbar
und das gute ist dazu braucht dieser
ost-club gar keinen ostbeauftragten
sondern einfach viel Enthusiasmus viele
zehntausende Fans und eine clevere
Clubführung so geht das übrigens im
ganzen Osten wenn man uns denn machen
lässt nur das ist das Problem Kollege
Merz hat es angesprochen die
Vermögensbildung da hängen wir natürlich
meilenweit hinterher wir hätten uns am
Anfang direkt nach der Wende auch
gewünscht vielleicht ein
niedrigsteuergebiet im Osten zu haben
vielleicht hätten wir schneller aufholen
können aber das ist natürlich vergossene
Milch wir müssen hier daran aber
arbeiten wir haben nach der friedlichen
Revolution im Osten wirklich losgelegt
das kann man sagen das war eine schwere
Zeit für viele gerade für die Generation
unserer Eltern sie mussten neu anfangen
sich umorientieren sie haben sich mit
viel Fleiß und Durchhaltevermögen über
die Jahre dann ein bisschen Wohlstand
erarbeitet aber sie sehen nun wie mit
einer völlig irrsinnigen Politik alles
kaputt zu gehen droht die
Energieknappheit lässt die Preise
explodieren
die Politik sagt einfach weiter so noch
mehr Windräder noch mehr von der Medizin
die uns 20 Jahre lang kaputt gemacht hat
mehr von dem Unsinn der unsere
Industrienation ruinieren könnte und das
regt viele Bürger völlig zu Recht auf
ich finde wir können den ostdeutschen
sehr dankbar sein die diese Gefahr genau
spüren und deswegen jetzt auf die Straße
gehen sie wollen die Politiker endlich
wach rütteln erleben aber wie sich die
ampelregierung darüber streitet ob zwei
oder drei Kernkraftwerke ein paar Monate
weiterlaufen dürfen was für eine bankrot
Ernährung in dieser Lage meine Damen und
Herren
der Kanz
ler hat ja die Lösung
ja wir müssen uns unterhaken wir müssen
uns alle Bürger unterhaken in Ost wie in
West und diese Politik diese irrsinnige
Politik zu Lasten der eigenen Bürger
endlich stoppen
ja und wir müssen die Demokratie
wiederbeleben es verstört ostdeutsche
Demokraten zum Beispiel zutiefst wenn in
Thüringen Wahlen rückgängig gemacht
werden und dann auch noch die
versprochene Neuwahlen einfach nicht
stattfinden deswegen ist es doch
verständlich viele Bürger im Osten
einfach diese Demokratie in einem
schlechten Zustand sehen und das liegt
nicht daran dass sie etwas gegen die
Demokratie haben sondern dass sie echte
Demokratie für alle haben wollen
über die Hälfte der ostdeutschen glaubt
dass die Meinungsfreiheit unter Druck
geraten ist und auch hier bin ich froh
dass wir Ossis eine wertvolle Erfahrung
mit in unser Land einbringen können wir
wissen nämlich wie sich Unfreiheit
anfühlt und wir sind froh dass wir uns
1989 die Freiheit erkämpft haben und
deshalb werden wir auch nicht zulassen
dass uns diese Freiheit wieder
schleichend genommen wird
wir brauchen kein betreutes Denken durch
Politik und Medien wir wissen selbst was
gut für uns ist wir brauchen niemanden
der uns vorschreibt wie wir zu leben und
zu sprechen haben den ganzen gender
Quatsch wollen wir nicht weil einfach
Blödsinn ist
wir brauchen keine Warnhinweise im TV
über angebliche Stereotypen bei Winnetou
oder beim Märchenfilm wie der kleine
Muck und wir lassen unsere Kinder auch
gerne weiter als Indianer zum Fasching
gehen weil es einfach normal ist
und wir halten es sogar für bewiesen
dass exakt zwei biologische Geschlechter
existieren und noch drastischer wir
lieben unser Land und finden da
überhaupt nichts dabei weil es ebenso
normal ist es ist unser Land und wir
wollen dafür sorgen dass wir eine
vernünftige rationale und ideologische
Politik bekommen die mit uns leben lässt
ich komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin
Energie statt Ideologie muss es jetzt
heißen sorgen sie endlich für eine
sichere bezahlbare Energieversorgung und
für eine geringe Abgabenlast dann können
wir auch weiter ran klotzen und hören
Sie bitte auf mit der ständigen
bevorstehung
wir sind wie wir sind und wir wollen
bleiben wie wir sind vielen Dank
das Wort erhält für die FDP-Fraktion
lindert heute Berg
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Ostdeutschland ein neuer Blick
so hat der Beauftragte der
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland den
Bericht überschrieben und ich finde wir
sollten auch einen neuen Blick wagen und
um es kurz bei der beschränkten Redezeit
die wir heute für dieses wichtige Thema
haben abzuhandelnde Antrag der Linken
wird diesen Anspruch mal einen neuen
Blick zu wagen und wirklich nicht
gerecht die Themen sind sehr wichtig
Inflation und Armut Löhne und Renten
wirtschaftliche und finanzielle Fragen
wahrlich allerdings beschäftigen wir uns
damit auch in vielen anderen
Tagesordnungspunkten hier im Haus genau
mit dem wichtigen Themen Inflation
bekämpfen wirtschaftliche Substanz
sichern und vieles mehr und die Fragen
der deutschen Einheit erschöpfen sich
allerdings nicht in Statistiken und
Fragen von Geld und Finanzen da gehört
noch sehr viel mehr dazu
allerdings will ich sehr wohl zu den
wirtschaftlichen Fragen weil sie wichtig
sind mit Blick auf Ostdeutschland etwas
sagen allerdings mit ganz anderem Akzent
denn gerade die Menschen im Osten
unseres Landes die erst vor 32 Jahren
die Chance bekommen haben unter
marktwirtschaftlichen Bedingungen auch
sich selbstständig zu machen die Früchte
ihrer Arbeit unter
Wettbewerbsbedingungen zu bekommen
gerade die haben ein Gespür dafür
vielleicht mehr als manche andere dass
unser Land kein Abo auf Wohlstand hat
sondern dass das Voraussetzungen hat die
wir sichern müssen denn gerade die
Menschen
im Osten unserer Republik die
wissenstrom kommt nicht aus der
Steckdose und Wohlstand nicht aus der
geldpressung genau deshalb haben sie ein
Gespür dafür was wir jetzt tun müssen
dazu gehört allerdings vieles wirklich
Inflationsbekämpfung als große Priorität
genau daran arbeiten wir deshalb müssen
wir bei der kalten Progression zum
Beispiel genauso konsequent sein wir
müssen eigentums- und Vermögensbildung
übrigens
die müssen wir erleichtern ich glaube
allerdings dass Ludwig Erhard zum
Beispiel da vor allem geschaut hätte was
machen wir hier eigentlich für
Regulierungen und fragen wir uns bei
jedem Gesetz dass wir hier beschließen
ob es eigentlich eigentums- und
Vermögensbildung in breiten Schichten
unserer Bevölkerung erleichtert oder
erschwert das wäre eine wichtige
prüfffrage liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
gerade weniger Bürokratie ein
Planungsrecht das mehr ermöglicht als
verhindert Regulierung die nicht nur
große Unternehmen mit Rechtsabteilungen
sondern auch Existenzgründer und
Mittelstand bewältigen können dass es
gerade für Ostdeutschland wichtig
und das zum Beispiel die vielen die sich
selbstständig gemacht haben nach der
Wiedervereinigung zum Beispiel auch
motiviert sind und auch andere finden
die motiviert sind ihre Unternehmen zu
übernehmen auch dafür brauchen wir
bessere Rahmenbedingungen in unserem
Land um all das geht es und zugleich
möchte ich ansprechen dass es nicht nur
um Wirtschaft und Finanzen geht sondern
um einiges mehr was in den letzten 30
Jahren zu kurz gekommen ist nämlich auch
die Frage wie reden wir miteinander und
übereinander wenn zusammenwachsen soll
was zusammen gehört da müssen wir uns
auch bewusst machen dass 40 Jahre der
Teilung auch eine längere Zeit der
Heilung benötigen und wie wir
miteinander und übereinander reden ist
ganz entscheidend dafür ob diese Heilung
gelingt ich möchte ein Beispiel nennen
aus den letzten Tagen mit Wolfgang
Kohlhase ist ein großer Drehbuchautor
unseres Landes verstorben und ob uns
eigentlich immer bewusst ist dass eben
auch zum Beispiel viele Künstler aus dem
Osten unseres Landes ganz unabhängig von
politischen System indem sie gelebt
haben unsere kulturelles Erbe bereichert
haben das mit Wolfgang Kohlhase jemand
verstorben ist der den gesamtdeutschen
Filmbereich hat ich finde das sind auch
wichtige Themen was ist unser
gemeinsames kulturelles Gedächtnis wenn
ich etwa ein Günter de bruyen denke
einen berühmten Schriftsteller aus
meiner Heimat Brandenburg der hat schon
zu DDR-Zeiten betont der ist kein
DDR-Schriftsteller ist ein deutscher
Autor der in der DDR lebt und ich finde
nach diesem Motto sollten wir uns mehr
mit unserem gemeinsamen kulturellen
Gedächtnis auch beschäftigen
und schließlich
mit dem Blick auf die aktuelle Situation
und auch den Zahlen der aktuellen
Erhebungen die in diesem Bericht
referiert werden da muss uns natürlich
Sorge machen wie gering und wie abnehmen
das Vertrauen Institutionen ist die
Zustimmung zu Demokratie und
Marktwirtschaft wenngleich das ein
gesamtdeutsches Problem ist dass in
Ostdeutschland noch stärker zum Tragen
kommt aber uns überall beschäftigen muss
auch dafür ist wichtig wie wir
miteinander und übereinander reden und
wenn wir die Streitkultur in unserer
Demokratie stärken wollen dann sollten
wir uns vielleicht auch öfter fragen
packen wir zu oft Menschen in Schubladen
und beurteilen die Frage was jemand
politisch vorbringt danach ob er oder
sie aus einer bestimmten Region unseres
Landes kommt muss er oder sie so denken
weil er oder sie aus dem Osten kommt
oder streiten wir leidenschaftlich um
die Argumente in der Sache auch das
könnte zu mehr
Demokratie und zu mehr Begeisterung für
Demokratie beitragen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
wir haben auch noch viel an diesem
gemeinsamen kulturellen historischen
Gedächtnis aufzuarbeiten deshalb will
ich hier einmal kurz sagen es ist auch
wichtig dass wir die Forschungsverbünde
zur Aufarbeitung der SED-Diktatur die
Landschaften der Verfolgung an unseren
Universität weiterführen und das
geplante
Zukunft ausgest
alten sagen können wir gemeinsam sind
Deutschland vielen Dank
lindert heute Berg war das für die
FDP-Fraktion hat hier unter anderem ein
gemeinsames kulturelles Gedächtnis
gefordert Dietmar Bartsch spricht als
nächstes für die Linksfraktion
erstraktionsvorsitzender auf einmal
jetzt alles Union Berlin finden geworden
ist also ich war schon da als die noch
in der dritten Liga gespielt haben da
lohnt sich zu kämpfen der Erfolg hat
dann immer viele Väter nur der
Misserfolg ist halten Waisenkind meine
Damen und Herren ich begrüße
ausdrücklich das Carsten Schneider
ostbeauftragter der Bundesregierung
geworden ist weil er kennt die Probleme
des Ostens bemüht sie auch um Lösungen
und ich finde auch dass die Neuartigkeit
des Berichtes einen wirklicher
Fortschritt ist das hebt sich wohltuend
von den Vorgängern ab aber man muss auch
klar feststellen die Bilanz der Ampel
nach einem Jahr ist was den Osten
betrifft ausgesprochen dürftig ja der
Mindestlohn ist wirklich etwas sehr
Wichtiges 12 Euro wir haben ja auch
zugestimmt aber
zehn Prozent Inflation sind dann eben
real doch nur zehn Euro 80 und Frau
Teuteberg 1 muss man ja mal sagen die
energie-krise trifft den Osten natürlich
umso härter viel stärker als viel im
Westen wir haben geringere Löhne wir
haben weniger private Vermögen weniger
Rücklagen bei Unternehmen das ist die
Wahrheit laut einer Umfrage sieht sich
jede zweite Firma im Osten von
insolvenzbedroht es brennt lichterlohen
der Wirtschaft im Osten wie im Westen
aber da müssen wir doch handeln und die
Bundesregierung handelt zu langsam und
sie handelt nicht entschlossen und damit
sind die Fortschritte der Einheit auf
dem Spiel meine Damen und Herren das ist
die Wahrheit ich bin sehr ich bin sehr
für ostdeutsches Selbstbewusstsein und
ich stehe da auch für für ostdeutsches
Selbstbewusstsein aber wenn wir zur
Kenntnis nehmen müssen oh real 74
Prozent der Menschen sind unzufrieden
mit der Ampel das ist die Wahrheit mit
der Demokratie sind im Osten nur noch 39
Prozent zufrieden zehn Prozent wichtiger
als im corona-jahr das sind
erschreckende Zahlen und die sind nicht
vom Himmel gefallen meine Damen und
Herren und da zählen natürlich die
ökonomischen Fakten das ist weiterhin so
12.000 Euro weniger verdienen
Ostdeutsche
vollzeitarbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer kein ostdeutsches
Bundesland ist auch nur in der Nähe des
schlechtesten westdeutschen Bundeslandes
Schleswig-Holstein mein Heimatland
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist leider auf
dem letzten Platz oder nehmen wir die
Wirtschaft
50 Prozent ist das Niveau im Vergleich
zum besten das sagt ja erstmal noch gar
nichts aber vor 20 Jahren im Jahre 2002
da waren es 68 Prozent wenn das so
weitergeht dauert das noch ein halbes
Jahrhundert aber ich wollte das
eigentlich noch erleben die Angleichung
der Lebensverhältnisse da muss mehr
geschehen meine Damen und Herren
Carsten Schneider hat ja zu Recht
erwähnt dass die Führungspositionen des
Landes zu wenig besetzt sind aber jetzt
sage ich mal von ihren Abteilungsleitern
in der Bundesregierung von 111 sind sage
und schreibe vier aus den neuen Ländern
das ist doch völlig inakzeptabel sie
sind eine westdeutsche Ampel und eine
Studie der Uni Kassel sagt selbst unter
Helmut Kohl war das besser das muss
ihnen doch zu denken geben meine Damen
und Herren lieber Carsten Schneider
kommen gleich zum Ende sie haben
inzwischen Büro im Bundeskanzleramt das
ist gut das haben wir immer gefordert
nehmen sie energisch die Interessen war
wir brauchen schutzstimmen gegen
Inflation und Armut retten sie vor allen
Dingen Schwedt die Jobs die Stadt und
die Region und vor allen Dingen sorgen
sie für Lohnarbeit für einheitliche
Entschuldigung für lohneinheit in
unserem Land 32 Jahre sind wirklich zu
lange ostdeutsches Selbstbewusstsein ja
aber bitte bitte mehr tun und nehmen Sie
das Angebot von Herr Merz ausdrücklich
an wir sind auch bereit damit zu tun
herzlichen Dank
Dietmar Barth hat hier diese
erschreckende Zahl genannt 39 Prozent
der Ostdeutschen sind noch mit der
Demokratie zufrieden
allerdings auch in Westdeutschland gab
es dort einen Rückgang wir sind noch 59
Prozent mit der Demokratie zufrieden vor
zwei Jahren waren es allerdings noch 65
Ministerpräsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen lieber Staatsminister
Schneider zunächst möchte ich mich für
den vorgelegten Bericht des Beauftragten
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland
wirklich bedanken die neue Berichtsform
ist wie er bereits dargestellt wurde ein
Novum sie bietet die Möglichkeit dass
der Osten durch Gastbeiträge selbst zu
Wort kommt und das ist wichtig weil es
eben nicht nur einen Blick von außen auf
aktuelle Entwicklung zulässt sondern
auch eine binnensicht ermöglicht und
diese binnensicht waren im Wort zu
machen ist ein Zeichen des Respekts
[Applaus]
diese binnensicht sowohl auf
Problemlagen als auch
Entwicklungschancen ist eben deutlich
differenzierter und vielschichtiger als
oftmals wahrgenommen danke auch an sie
haben märz für ihren nachdenklichen
Beitrag und die konstruktiven Vorschläge
vielen Dank wir kommen darauf zurück
meine Damen und Herren es gibt ihnen
nicht den einen Osten der oftmals von
den politischen Rändern vereinnahmt wird
und deshalb lassen Sie mich noch ein
paar Worte anschließend an Herrn Kellner
zu den aktuellen Demonstrationen von
links wie rechts sagen
Krisen Frust und auch Angst vor den
aktuellen Situationen treiben Menschen
auf die Straße das ist alles völlig
verständlich und auch nachvollziehbar
man muss halt nur schauen mit wem oder
hinter wem man sich da versammelt
und deswegen an dieser Stelle mal ein
klares Wort an alle die mit politisch
extrem marschieren und sich selbst in
der Tradition von 1989 sehen 22 ist
nicht 89 im Oktober 1989 musste ich mich
mit meiner Frau immer genau abstimmen
wer wann zu welcher Demonstration geht
unsere Tochter war ein Jahr alt beide
Eltern gemeinsam zu Demonstration das
ging einfach nicht aus Verhandlungen
gegenüber dem Kind kommen wir nach Hause
zurück und als ich mit dem Zug vom
damaligen Karl-Marx-Straße Hauptbahnhof
zum Montag 7 Uhr nach Leipzig gefahren
bin rettete mich mein Dienstausweis als
Lokomotivführer wovor sich vor Zuführung
weil es damals eben nicht nur um
Verhaftungen im Vorfeld von Demos ging
sondern einfach gesagt und Zuführungen
einfaches raus- und Aufgreifen von
potenziellen Demonstranten im
Stadtgebiet durch die Volkspolizei im
Bahnhof oder im Zug durch die
Transportpolizei und grundloses
festhalten stundenlang in
polizeiobjekten links und rechts von mir
wurden Leute zugeführt einfach so ohne
der Grund Zuführung Festsetzung Klärung
eines Sachverhalts gern auch 48 Stunden
lang und heute
hinter Russland fahren
reichskriegsflaggen und mit querblichen
T-Shirts initiiert auch von AFD Landes-
dieses System garantiert Ihnen dass Sie
alles mögliche und eigentlich auch
Unmögliches sagen rufen uns skandieren
können dieses System ist ein
unabhängigen Gerichte und die Polizei
schützen sie und ihre Demonstrationen
dieses System schützt ihre Rechte auf
Meinungsfreiheit und Protest und deshalb
und deshalb das ist sehr persönlich
hören Sie endlich auf die jetzigen
Demonstrationen in den Kontext und in
die Historie zu den Demos 1989 zu
stellen das ist unredlich geschichts
vergessen und ein Verrat an der
friedlichen Revolution von 89
gibt es Fraktion
en Applaus für Detlef Müller der unter
anderem ja auch die
Demonstrationsfreiheit hingewiesen hat
die
eindeutig besteht um eben auch
den Unmut kund zu tun
Jana Schimke jetzt für die
Unionsfraktion liebe Besucherinnen und
Besucher auf den auf der Tribüne wenn
ich in meinen persönlichen Eindruck
schildern darf dann ist dies der dass
unser Jahr nach 32 Jahren dass unser
Land nach 32 Jahren deutsche Einheit so
gespalten ist wie noch nie zuvor
politisch gesellschaftlich und wenn es
so weitergeht auch bald wirtschaftlich
wir haben seit dem 1 Oktober allein in
den neuen Bundesländern 263 Insolvenzen
Tendenz steigen wir kennen alle die
Namen wo deta GmbH das sind die Grünen
eukalyptusbonbons mussten dicht machen
wegen steigenden Energiepreisen und
Rohstoffpreisen die Campus Seifen GmbH
aus Riesa unterlag den Preissteigerungen
Energiekosten und Personal
Personalkosten die Ludwig Leuchten GmbH
aus Elsterheide Sachsen ein 70-jähriges
Unternehmen musste dicht machen wegen
unterbrochenen Lieferketten und auch
Carla Porzellan wer hat es nicht zu
Hause in der Vitrine zu stehen ein alter
Betrieb seit 1844 am Markt musste dicht
machen weil der Gasversorger geschlossen
hat und es keinen neuen Gasversorger
gibt meine Damen und Herren was wir
gerade erleben ist gefühlt eine zweite
d-industriealisierung der neuen
Bundesländer und das liebe
Bundesregierung
das liebe Bundesregierung liegt auch an
ihrer Politik und die Umfragen geben
berechtigterweise Anlass zur Sorge
56 Prozent
der Deutschen halten heute die deutsche
Einheit nicht als geglückt 77 Prozent
finden dass es in Deutschland nicht
gerecht zugeht 63 Prozent sagen sie sind
Menschen zweiter Klasse und ebenso viele
sagen dass die Demokratie sich
verschlechtert hat zur Wahrheit gehört
aber auch liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass die Westdeutschen Bundesbürger ein
ähnliches Stimmverhalten haben etwas
weniger aber trotzdem ähnlich und wissen
Sie was das große Problem der Debatte
ist auch am heutigen Tage dass sie immer
wieder die falschen Schlussfolgerungen
treffen und das zeigt sich schon allein
am Blick in den Bericht zur deutschen
Einheit da werden nämlich die Menschen
unterschieden in offen und liberal meine
Damen und Herren wer ist denn offen und
liberal in Deutschland wenn ich Ihren
Bericht lese dann sind es diejenigen die
vor allen Dingen in Umweltschutz und den
Klimawandel an erster Stelle ihrer
wichtigsten themenstellen dann kommt
erstmal eine ganze Weile nicht bis dann
irgendwann die soziale Gerechtigkeit
kommt und es sind auch jene die die
höchste corona-im Angebote haben was
hatten bitte eine corona-impfquote im
Bericht zur deutschen Einheit verloren
aber es geht ja noch weiter die nächsten
Kategorien
kleinbürgerlich konservativ ich weiß gar
nicht ob wir uns als Union dazu zählen
dürfen 24 Prozent der Ostdeutschen sind
das die haben einen Mut zum starken
Nationalgefühl dann kommen aber auch
schon die angepassten Skeptiker mit 26
Prozent und last but not least
verdrossene Populisten mit 35 Prozent
Liebe Bundesregierung 85 Prozent der
Ostdeutschen werden durch sie in so eine
verschworbelte Ecke geschoben wo ich
mich frage wie wollen wir eigentlich
noch zueinander finden meine Damen und
Herren der Osten ist nicht abgehangen
die Dörfer sind durchsaniert wir hatten
rekordbeschäftigung bis zuletzt wir
hatten volle Auftragsbücher zurück in
ihre alte Heimat um dort zu leben die
Leute wollen nicht von oben herab
behandelt werden sie wollen keine
Belehrungen sie wollen keine
Besserwisserei sie kennen ihre
Lebensleistung sie möchten nicht in die
linke und die rechte Ecke gesteckt
werden wir alle Lösungen keine
Beschimpfungen und keine Missionierungen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
jetzt kommen wir alle wieder runter denn
der nächste Redner ist Kassem taiasali
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Bernhard
alles gut ich glaube Frau Schimke ist es
aufgefallen wie beschämend gerade ihr
Redebeitrag war dass sie diese Debatte
gerade hier
die Süddeutschland verwenden über ihre
Ideologien zu verwenden und machen die
dich eins klar in der Mehrheiten diese
Landesregierung ist auch die CDU
beteiligt
vielleicht noch Einsatz zu Ihnen
[Applaus]
ich glaube ich an wirklich überhaupt
keine Ahnung mal was da wo wurde ich
geht in Ordnung aus Deutschland wissen
sie das
sie sie werden niemals bei Union Berlin
jemals ein Spiel sehen diese Fanszene
ist viel zu links und viel zu radikal
für ihre Ideologie
meine Damen und Herren liebe
Besucherinnen und Besucher ich bin
plauna ich bin Dresdner ich bin Sachse
ich bin ostdeutscher am Tag der
Deutschen Einheit habe ich das in einem
Tweet geschrieben dies hat man mir in
unzähligen Kommentaren direkt
abgesprochen
ich möchte aber hier nicht gerade
darüber sprechen ob ich zu
Ostdeutschland gehöre oder nicht sondern
ob Ostdeutschland eigentlich dazugehört
natürlich gehört Ost und Westdeutschland
schon lange zusammen wir waren noch nie
so wieder vereint wie heute aber meine
Damen und Herren die deutsche Einheit
ist noch nicht vollkommen
wir haben immer noch nicht die gleichen
Chancen auch Führungspositionen und den
gesellschaftlichen Aufstieg wir haben
Ungleichheiten bei Löhnen bei Renten bei
Vermögen unter Tarifbindung
diese Ungleichheiten sind strukturell
bedingt und es ist unsere Verantwortung
unserer Aufgabe auch hier im Parlament
diese Ungleichheiten zu beseitigen
der
Strukturwandel in Ostdeutschland hat das
Zeug vieles schlagartig zu verändern und
voranzubringen und zwar für ganz
Deutschland die Energiewende die
bauwände das Handwerk grüne innovative
Technologien die Wissenschaft das
Potenzial ist riesig das zukunftszentrum
für deutsche Einheit und europäische
Transformation in Leipzig und Plauen
wäre ein gutes Beispiel dafür
[Applaus]
wir brauchen wir brauchen solche
Projekte
die den Fokus auf die immer noch
nachwirkenden gesellschaftlichen
Umbrüche lenken wir müssen dies im
kulturellen und im historischen
Gedächtnis auch von Westdeutschen fest
verankern wie es im Bericht vom
Staatsminister Schneider auch zu treffen
beschrieben ist
wenn die AFD und Konsorten
steigende migrationsteilen steigenden
geflüchteten zahlen und soziale
Ungleichheiten dafür nutzen um zu
aufmerksam zu mobilisieren dann sollte
es Menschen so dann sollte es in
Menschen in Stuttgart oder in Hamburg
genauso interessieren wie in Görlitz
oder in Leipzig das meine Damen und
Herren kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss das
meine Damen und Herren ist ein
gesellschaftliches ist ein gesamtdeutsch
Problem ein letzten Satz frau
Präsidentin muss aber sehr kurz sein den
mache ich auch sehr kurz wir
nachwendekinder sind die neuen
vielfältigen Stimmen des Ostens und wir
spiegeln auch seinen stetigen wandeln
auch wieder es braucht diese stimmen
damit alle die Herausforderungen der
Einheit nach 30 Jahren auch erkennen
meine Stimme gehört dazu vielen Dank
so die Stimmung scheint jetzt hier
wieder etwas versöhnlicher geworden zu
sein nachdem es besonders zwischen Union
und Grünen bzw dort zwischen einzelnen
Abgeordnete doch sehr lauter
Auseinandersetzungen gab Matthias
Helferich spricht jetzt erst
fraktionslos
Kosten sich die Westdeutschen
angetrieben durch ihre Eliten von
Deutschland und dem Fluch Deutsche zu
sein sie sehnten sich nach dem Aufgehen
Westdeutschlands im Westen sein
materiellen Werten nach der
Wiedervereinigung erhofften sich jene
westdeutschen Eliten das Ostdeutschland
im Westen verschwinden würde die
Ostdeutschen wollten aber keine
westdeutschen sein sondern wie es der
Publizist Eberhard Straub schrieb
endlich deutsche sein über Jahrzehnte
war unser Volk in seiner Geisteswelt in
Ost- und West getrennt doch der Bericht
des Beauftragten für Ostdeutschland
zeigt auf dass diese Trennung zunehmend
verschwindet Bürger in Ost und West eint
dass sie das Vertrauen in den
Parteienstaat verloren haben dass freie
Wort gefährdet sehen sie eint dass sie
sich nach Mut zum Nationalstolz und
einer nationalen Erzählung einen
nationalen Mythos sehen vereint sind sie
auch darin als verdrossene Populisten
oder angepasste Skeptiker durch ihren
Bericht diffamiert zu werden wenn sich
ihren Dogmen entziehen doch schon ernst
Jünger warnte dass ein Fehler sein nach
dem Erdbeben auf den Seismographen
einzuschlagen sie machen in ihrem
Bericht genau diesen Fehler Sie suchen
nicht die Ursachen für die wachsende
Ablehnung ihrer Politik in Osten und
West sondern versuchen den protester
gegen zu diskretieren das Erdbeben die
Erhebung weiterteile unseres Volkes
in Ost und West gegen ihre Politik
sollte jedoch Anlass zu Überprüfung
ihrer Politik sein und Uwe Telkamp gibt
uns allen einen entscheidenden Rat ich
zitiere was ist denn ein Volk überhaupt
es ist eine gemeinsame prägende Kultur
und wenn diese sich nicht mehr langsam
und organisch sondern plötzlich und
disruptiv verändert dann ist das
traumatisch zum Beispiel wenn sich
Menschen in ihren eigenen Städten nicht
mehr zu Hause sondern fremd vorkommen
dann muss man das ernst nehmen das heißt
wir müssen damit anfangen darüber
natürlich in aller gesittetheit aber
endlich offen zu diskutieren beginnen
wir endlich darüber zu diskutieren in
Ost und West vielen Dank
[Applaus]
vereinzelt Applaus für den ehemaligen
afd-abgeordneten jetzt fraktionslos auf
jeden Fall und Dieter Stier für die
Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im ganz neuen
Gewand präsentiert sich der
einheitsbericht in seiner aktuellen
Ausgabe die bunte Aufmachung soll mit
der überlieferten Routine brechen und
zumindest das Herr Staatsminister
Schneider ist ihnen gelungen doch wir
alle wissen ein neues Outfit löst noch
lange nicht die alten Probleme und eines
dieser Probleme da sind ihren Bericht
nicht einmal vorkommt aber auf das
Ängste mit der deutschen Einheit
verbunden ist ist immer noch ungelöst
ich spreche von der aktuellen
flächenvergabe durch die bundeseigene
BVVG der bodenverwertungs- und
Verwaltungs GmbH einst errichtet im
Auftrag der auf der Grundlage des
treuhandgesetzes mit eindeutigen Auftrag
im einheitsbericht habe ich zumindest
auf 152 Seiten dazu kein einziges Wort
gefunden und das obwohl das Thema
Landwirtschaft in Ostdeutschland unter
den Nägeln brennt
als drei Jahrzehnte nach der
Wiedervereinigung ist die Privatisierung
der volkseigenen Flächen zugunsten
unserer Landwirte immer noch nicht
abgeschlossen wer blockiert die
Bundesregierung warum weil die Grünen
die ökologische Landwirtschaft einseitig
bevorzugen und die konventionellen
Landwirte benachteiligen wollen der
gegenwärtige Verkauf sind
verpachtungsstopp für
landwirtschaftliche Flächen wirkt dabei
wie ein riesiger Bremsklotz auf einer
Zielgeraden die wir schon lange
eingeschlagen hatten und die uns durch
das Ideologie getriebene agieren jetzt
wieder im Jahre zurückwerfen wird mit
dieser gezielten Bevorzugung verstoßen
sie meines Erachtens klar gegen
geltendes Recht vor allem zwischen die
privatisierungsgrundsätze die zwischen
Bund und den ostdeutschen Ländern auch
vereinbart sind und weil der
Bundesfinanzminister richtigerweise
gegen diese Ideologie
Widerstand leistet streiten sie sich und
es basiert ein Jahr nichts die Ampel
steht hier seit einem Jahr auf rot
Stillstand Lösung trotz Ankündigung
nicht in Sicht und das ist aus meiner
Sicht für den ländlichen Raum
unverantwortlich ich fordere Sie auf
sperren sie sich nicht weiter gegen eine
ausgewogene Lösung geben Sie die
flächenfrei tragen Sie dazu bei dass
BVVG ihren gesetzlichen Auftrag
ungehindert erfüllen kann haben Sie
bitte zum Schluss das mache ich frau
Präsidentin es liegt jetzt an allein an
Ihnen dass wir dieses Kapitel im Buch
der deutschen Einheit erfolgreich
abschließen können und wenn dann heute
die Redezeit für dieses wichtige Thema
so knapp ist dann hoffe ich zumindest
das ist den Parteitag der Grünen
geschuldet dass sie wenigstens kluge
Beschlüsse zur Energiepolitik dort
treffen vielen Dank
Dieter Stier war das muss dazu sagen
dass jetzt die CDU auch durchaus schon
mal ein Parteitag an einem Sitzungstag
an einem Freitag begonnen hat also diese
Kritik ist dann vielleicht auch an die
eigene Partei dass wir natürlich nicht
Katrin Budde ist jetzt hier die letzte
Rednerin sie ist Mitglied der
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
mein Gott Herr Merz dass ich das noch
mal sage hätten sie nur die gesamte
Redezeit für die cdu/csu genutzt zu
dieser Debatte
der Bericht des super bitte lassen Sie
ihn so Herr Staatsminister nicht wieder
nur Daten und Fakten und ich empfehle
allen wirklich allen insbesondere den
Teil A zu lesen ich würde ihnen geradezu
zur Pflichtliteratur für jeden
Bundestagsabgeordneten machen danach
werden sie den Osten besser verstehen
denn es ist natürlich noch so 32 Jahre
nach der Wiedervereinigung haben wir
gegenseitig nur bruchstückhaftes
verstehen der Gefühlswelten in Ost und
West wir haben ja auch andere Biografien
hinter uns das ist kein einseitiger
Vorwurf sondern ich meine dass durchaus
wie wir früher sagten über und drüber
ich war kürzlich erst wieder in einer
Situation die das ganz gut beschreibt
ich habe nämlich versucht zu erklären
dass die Besonderheiten der Brüche im
Osten der Verluste die in
Fragestellungen im Leben nach 1990 die
habe ich beschrieben die Größe und das
Ausmaß der in jedem Winkel der Familien
des Lebens und das alltagskriechenden
Veränderungen und dann bekomme ich fast
trotzig eine Antwort aber es ist schon
eine Erfolgsgeschichte
wenn schon antworte ja komme ich aber
gar nicht weiter um zu erklären was ich
weiter meine wenn ich Ansätze weiter zu
reden dann kommt aber das ist doch schon
das Wichtigste und im übrigen im Westen
hat sich auch ganz viel verändert wenn
es doch eine gefolgserfolgsgeschichte
ist dann brauche ich mich ja nicht mit
der Gefühlswelt des Volkes dahinter
irgendwie brauche ich mich auf die nicht
einzulassen aber genau das ist der
Fehler denn die Antwort lautet ja das
ist eine Erfolgsgeschichte und nein wir
haben nicht alles richtig gemacht und
neben Daten Fakten und Situationen da
gibt es auch noch die Gesellschaft und
die Gesellschaft die hat sowas wie eine
kollektive Seele als ich das erste Mal
von kollektiven gesellschaftlichen
Traumata gelesen habe habe ich an
Kriegserfahrungen von Völkern gedacht an
Holocaust und das ist zum ersten Mal in
Verbindung mit der Wiedervereinigung
gehört habe da habe ich das ganz weit
von mir gewesen heute denke ich anders
darüber auch eine gute und richtige
Entwicklung und gute und richtige
Ergebnisse
nie Wiedervereinigung können durch die
strukturbrüche die diesen Prozess
begleiten zu gesellschaftlichen und
nicht nur zu individuellen Verletzungen
führen und das ist verdammt gefährlich
und das sehen wir überall
und natürlich können die Ostdeutschen
dumme Demokratie wir haben sie uns sogar
im Gegensatz zu den westdeutschen selber
erkämpft aber ostdeutsche erwarten mehr
und anderes davon das gehört auch zum
Teil der Wahrheit es ist ja nun aber
nicht nur unsere Aufgabe zurückzublicken
und Gegenwart zu beschreiben sondern
auch eine gemeinsame Zukunft zu
ermöglichen was also tun ich will mal
holzschnittartig das in drei Punkten
beschreiben erstens die Leistung der
ostdeutschen der letzten 32 Jahre
wirklich anerkennen zweitens uns darüber
verständigen dass wir gemeinsames neues
auf Augenhöhe wollen und drittens uns
vereinbaren was das neue gemeinsame ist
dafür braucht man Orte dafür braucht man
Prozesse dafür braucht man Forschung
Entwicklung Wissenschaft Kunst Kultur
bürgerdialoge und ein solcher Ort ein
solcher Ort wird das zukunftszentrum für
deutsche Einheit und europäische
Transformation sein
Katrin Budde war das die letzte Rednerin
in dieser gut 40-minütigen Debatte diese
Vorlagen sollen allerdings jetzt an die
entsprechenden Ausschüsse überwiesen
werden das bedeutet dass dann auch der
die Abgeordneten noch einmal drüber
sprechen können und auch die Vorlagen
noch mal hier im Plenum zu Diskussion
gestellt werden denn das Thema ist ja
mit nichtem hier aus diskutiert